the overriding question being asked
tonight is just how did they miss it
after repeated warnings and multiple
referrals the authorities in bradford
failed to recognize eight months of
abuse leading to this child's murder
five times worried family and friends
called social services
but on each occasion their complaints
weren't thoroughly followed up or
ignored entirely
this comes down to the leadership at
bradford council not taking the whole of
this issue seriously enough and that's
why i do feel that the chief executive
and the leader should resign
guys and girls need to remember the fact
that frankie is with me
the warning signs were there in this
video savannah brockhill describes
herself as a number one psycho an
insight into the mind of someone who
would murder a baby
this was just one of many alarms raised
with the authorities
bradford council have apologized and
said they want to fully understand why
opportunities to protect star were
missed but it will ultimately be the
findings of yet another review which
could highlight the continuous failings
and see bradford lose control of its
children's services
it's an area of the council which has
seen three different bosses in three
years and ofsted reports in 2018 marked
it
inadequate how could every one of those
professionals and services and parts of
the system that should be on a high
alert to look for children who
are being harmed
not notice this we knew that we find out
that when she died that she had no
chance of living her injuries were so
awful there was no chance of living
following the murder of six-year-old
arthur lobinjo hughes by his stepmother
a national review is investigating what
lessons can be learned it will too take
into account the abuse star hobson faced
west yorkshire police say the ultimate
responsibility lies with the parent and
her partner
if star hobson
hadn't been treated as she'd been
treated by frankie smith her own mother
and savannah brockel then she would
still be alive
the decision to remove a child from a
parent is of course a hugely difficult
one and one social services across the
country have to face every day but what
seems apparent here is a lack of
investigative instinct and that could
potentially have been a fatal mistake
in zaman rashid sky news bradford